[Music]
Jim Parsons actor thesbian all-around
great guy also has a new radio show it's
called Jim Parsons is too stupid for
politics
this guy's doing it all and he's also in
hidden figures up for three Academy
Awards we discovered him I don't think
too many people knew who Jim Parsons was
and then he stumbled into Big Bang
Theory played God on Broadway has more
money than God right now and we brought
him on this program Jim good morning how
are you
I'm heavenly heavenly how are you I'm
spectacular are you uh are you nervous
about the Academy Awards no no I think
it'll be just another glorious evening
in Hollywood I don't know no I don't be
exciting they're really fun I'm going
alone it's a really hard ticket to get
so they only got me one so I'm going
stag have you been before no I've never
been before I've been to there's this
party that a lot of people go to it's
called the evening before party it
benefits the movie fund for actors and
stuff in retirement when they're sick
and stuff and um a lot of people go to
that so it's kind of a star-studded
thing but I imagine this will be a
little more star-studded a little more
jaw-dropping but we'll see who would you
want to meet at the Academy Awards God
do I want to meet I have trouble meeting
people outside of work that are other
actors like I had my like like this
party I'm talking about I've gone to and
it's thrown by the Katzenberg's every
Kathryn Burke of DreamWorks and his wife
Marilyn and they're really sweet and
she's all his wife is especially good
about she's like there's Meryl Streep
over there do you want to meet her in
like no not right now I mean what am I
just fallin over her and so it's kind of
hard I feel like it would be
accidentally stumbling upon somebody and
going oh I'm suddenly I'm in a
conversation with you how nice but
otherwise I kind of just hover around
until I actually meet somebody during
work like got to meet Kevin Costner
during the hidden figures thing but I
would have never just gone up to him is
that that's weird maybe that social
anxiety
my part well everybody thinks it's
mutual admiration society so you sort of
know each other because you're all
famous and so you walk up and say hey
will fair yeah you know there are times
where I guess that's sort of true you
know but at the same time it's not the
majority at least it's not for me it's
like I'm not gonna go bother somebody I
don't know they feel like that but I
always feel like that like I love your
don't know but people now you know what
it's like to be a fan to come up to you
and yeah that's true that's true and
that should make you life easier for me
on the other end because I think it's
very sweet when people come up to me
I don't know Dan I got problems I got
major problems usually and so it's not
working out I want to ask you about how
would that work how would you ever get a
show like dan dan leb Attard to come on
your show while he's doing his that
would be an amazing
could you simulcast that yeah I'm you
just go talk on both shows at the same
time couldn't you well I once offered
that to Jim Rome in AMPA at the Super
Bowl was it San Diego or Tampa for Diego
we ran into him okay and then I I went
by Jim Rome and he's ready to go on his
show and I was ready to go on mine and
then I I said he he said you know want
you if you want to come on my show I
said well come on my show at the same
time let's just we'll do an interview
and he said no I can't do that so I did
try to do that with your mouth goofy
that's such a good idea yeah he didn't
think so but look you know you're like a
radio producer now I like this you got
your own show Jim Parsons is too stupid
for politics yeah how much politics
Jesus that you just discuss well like we
started off it's really been weird I'm
trying to do I'm trying to do so I'm
trying to talk about things going on in
a way that keeps it a little more
factual a little less partisan a little
less venomous a little less heated and
that's that part's not been hard like
I'm kind of having fun doing that
because it's so easy to get passionately
wrapped up one way or the other when you
hear any bit of news and so it's really
nice to have this kind of checkpoints
and now built in I'm like well don't go
that way so you can just try and
so that part's not hard but it's been
hardest like anything we talked about
like last week we talked about health
care and the Affordable Care Act and the
week before that it was like about the
the immigrant band's last travel pause
whatever you want to call it and and
these issues get so deep so it's like I
mean I only got 45 50 minutes total by
the time you count the commercials and
everything and I feel like we go in with
20 questions and we come out with a
hundred you know I don't know I find it
very complicated but see I told you I'm
stupid in the title and so if I didn't
answer a damn thing what what were you
looking for who would you want to
interview on your show you know I really
like a lot of people that may not be
overly useful to me because it would
probably lean more partisan like I like
I'm a big fan of two people who I have
been on sort of different sides of the
spectrum like Rachel Maddow and megyn
kelly I really like both of them a lot
but I feel like you automatically guess
you've already taken a side just to
start the conversation but I think you
could have a conversation that's just
like how do how does your job go what's
it like to collect news during the day
how do you decide what stories to cover
I think that'd be interesting I'm a real
admin I just admire all those people
that that do that kind of stuff I am
gonna talk to an ex press secretary
today he was Clinton's press secretary
and I guess that has a partisan bent
just because he was on because he was
for Clinton democrat but at the same
time it's more just to kind of hear the
inner workings of what it's like to be
in that room you know nothing wrong with
letting people understand the process we
had bama's press secretary on you know
the last one yeah we had him on his
final day but we talked about you know
leaving the White House in the process
of it yeah but I I feel like people want
these hot takes that they want you to
have an opinion you have to write you
have to put something out there that
they can bite into right and you can't
you know just serve up the same meal
every day and and you know that that's
the hard part
and I tell anybody who does this job are
you willing to put yourself out there
right and if you're not then I would
tell you it's probably not the business
for you and being you know somebody
criticizing you right you know they've
but that it's difficult to do I'm
surprised you're doing it putting
yourself in that position well I am too
you know I as I've said a couple of
times as I kept talking about this for a
few months leading up to it I realized
at a certain point that subconsciously I
was waiting for somebody to go this is a
terrible idea
stop it and and nobody ever did and so
so now I'm here I mean look I could quit
this and they wouldn't they wouldn't
shed it's here over the period it's not
breaking news he's not quitting he said
he got quit
kind of jumped the gun there a little
bit there did he play yeah yeah the
break break but but I really do and this
is the fine line you're talking about I
mean the reason I'm still stupidly
bravely going forward is because of my
goal which is to keep things at a level
that the premise is never to
purposefully take too much stance on
anything it's really trying to dig into
because I think because like you say if
it's not sexy if it's not interesting
it's not worth hearing that's kind of
especially with regards to voting and
politics that's that's a problem because
that means that you skip over the meat
of a lot of things and you go straight
to battle and and there are times I
don't have a take on like you can't have
it made yeah we're talking to Jim
Parsons big bang theory of course hidden
figures up for three Academy Awards
if hidden figures wins yeah you going
stage yeah I I think that's how it works
I was just saying to somebody last night
where are you sitting and I said I
really don't know and it could be very
very far back but I said I don't think
it will be because I feel like any time
there's a Best Picture winner everyone
makes it up on stage from the cast and a
reasonable amount of time
bad Jim if jumping over balcony
it'll look bad if everybody's up there
and then they're waiting and waiting
right as the music goodbye everybody
breathless and sweaty is there something
that you could get a program maybe
something for the man cave here I mean
we're not going to offer yeah you got so
oh look now that you've said it all look
Gabi night wasn't gracious enough to
think of getting you anything even a
napkin from Mike that's what I'm saying
I'm fine maybe something from the
Governor's Ball or whatever yeah yeah
that's what I will do I'm gonna have to
write that on my hand Ramona forget it
no offense but it's just an overwhelming
time as you can imagine but but yeah I'm
death that not what a pleasure that
would be to get something for the man
cave from the Oscars and get a selfie
with Meryl Streep just go do it right I
have met her since then you know she's
gonna be just burdened with people
hanging all over her okay do you do you
give a handshake or do you give a hug
- who - Meryl Streep when you when you
meet her do you hug I take her cues and
I'm going I'm I'm approaching thinking I
should probably embrace her but that's
just because of my feelings of a of a
person I mostly know from screen not
from real life yeah and if she gets you
like you know I don't know what diseases
you have please keep it foot distance
then then then it will just shake but I
would take her cute I can't remember if
I hugged her before I met her in a more
intimate gathering at her last movie
because my calf mate Simon was in it
with her so it was a good way to meet
her but um all right well don't screw up
I'll try not yeah yeah and and we're
proud of you and you know we'll be we'll
be rooting for you I want to see you
onstage
yeah thank you and I'll run it later
you're waving to us when you're onstage
all right thank you Jim
thank you the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you